persona 5 is much more than just dungeon
crawling and stealing the hearts of
evildoers it's a rewarding excursion
through atlases vision of Tokyo in all
its subway connected urban glory
lifestyle activities like reading
magazines and watching movies will
enhance your attributes as does working
in restaurants the various districts
also provide opportunities to bond with
individual members of your party
sometimes in situations that might be
more than platonic this gameplay
Showcase offers just a sampling of what
you can do in areas like Shibuya and
Shinjuku if you enjoyed this persona 5
video give us a thumbs up and subscribe
to our channel while you're there check
out our history of persona video and if
you'd like to see other areas of persona
5 let us know in the discussion below
thanks for watching
Oh
Oh
[Music]
nice job
[Music]
and
[Music]
alright let's head back
[Music]
and
house
[Music]
the world of wine you spy quesadilla
range to get favor on a little taste
sensations you see when forced issues
kink or pie people so did exclude taste
I am nothing like you
you're a psychopath who bakes for money
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay all right
nice all right
one head back
[Music]
where you get your time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
okay what are your thoughts
[Music]
thank you very much
the real smelvin all right one head back
[Music]
all right
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wait
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
yes
[Music]
um
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
all right yeah
[Music]
my
[Music]
you